seit fast einem Jahrhundert
interpretieren Meinungsforscher die
öffentliche Meinung
möchten Sie an einer Umfrage zur
bevorstehenden Wahl teilnehmen ihre
Methode ist einfach sie stellen einer
kleinen Gruppe von Personen Fragen und
verwenden diese Stichprobe dann als
Repräsentanz für die Meinung der
gesamten Bevölkerung vielen Dank Sears
war schön Sie kennenzulernen nun gern
geschehen gute Nacht danke dass sie da
waren doch in den letzten Jahrzehnten
hat die Öffentlichkeit keine Lust mehr
Fragen Anrufe oder Türklingel zu
beantworten und die Menschen sind nicht
mehr nur an einem einzigen Ort
erreichbar sondern zunehmend mobil
geworden das macht traditionelle
Umfragen zu einer größeren
Herausforderung heutzutage äußern die
Menschen ihre Meinungen und Gewohnheiten
über mobil und Internettechnologien
inklusives Smartphones und soziale
Medien diese informationslawine
ermöglicht neue Methoden zu erforschen
was die Öffentlichkeit denkt
[Musik]
heute sind Daten überall verfügbar
Kreditkarteninformationen
kundenkarteninformationen demografische
Informationen und Informationen von
gemeinschaftsorganisationen denken Sie
an die Dinge für die sie sich anmelden
denken Sie an die Veranstaltungen diese
besuchen und wenn Sie auf das kleine
Kästchen klicken wo daneben steht ich
habe die Nutzungsbedingungen gelesen und
stimme ihnen zu dann ist das ein Vertrag
mehrere Seiten mit Sachen die sie sich
nicht durchgelesen haben die niemand
liest und es wäre auch egal wenn sie es
durchlesen würden das bedeutet dass wir
Informationen aus allen Teilen der Welt
erhalten und genau das macht sie so
wertvoll
viele Menschen geben Google ihre
E-Mail-Daten über Gmail ihre Videodaten
über Youtube und ihren Aufenthaltsort
über Google Maps wenn man also all diese
Daten miteinander verknüpft ist es
bemerkenswert welche intimes Bild ist
von einer Person zeichnet dass meiner
Meinung nach unser eigenes Gedächtnis in
den Schatten stellt und dass uns all die
Orte vergessen lässt an denen wir waren
[Musik]
die Herausforderung besteht darin aus
einem scheinbar zufälligen Rauschen
aussagekräftige Informationen zu
extrahieren
[Musik]
die angewandte künstliche Intelligenz
auch KI genannt birgt hier sowohl
Chancen als auch Risiken
[Musik]
während des topisches Science-Fiction
von Welten träumt in denen Maschinen
über Menschen herrschen verstehen ihre
Ingenieure KI eher als eine Maschine die
lernen und denken kann
sie betrachten sie als ein vom Menschen
gelenktes Werkzeug das lernt in dem es
riesige Datenmengen zum Beispiel aus
sozialen Medien verarbeitet und dann
Muster im Rauschen erkennt was wäre wenn
es eine KI gäbe die anhand dieser Muster
vorhersagen könnte wie sich Menschen in
der Zukunft verhalten zum Beispiel um
den Ausgang einer Wahl vorherzusagen
der Wahlkampf für die nächsten
kanadischen bundeswahlen hat soeben
begonnen
während Premierminister Justin todos
liberale Partei mit einem Justizskandal
und der Entlassung von zwei Ministern zu
tun hat haben die Konservativen die
neuen Demokraten und der blockcha alle
neue und unerprobte Führer
trotz eines knappen sechswöchigen
Wahlkampfes haben die Parteien nur
langsam ihre Programme vorgestellt es
ist unklar ob die Wähler Ihre Wahl auf
der Grundlage der Themen der Partei oder
der Spitzenkandidaten Treffen werden in
Kanadas Hauptstadt Ottawa nutzt ein
kleines Startup KI um die bevorstehenden
Wahlen vorherzusagen
die Leute nennen das die seinfeldwahl
wirklich weil es um nichts geht ja
obwohl das bei jeder Weise ist ich
glaube es ist eher das Gegenteil der
Fall um ehrlich zu sein die Leute haben
zu mir gesagt dass dies die erste Wahl
ist bei der sie tatsächlich auf die
Politik schauen und nicht auf die
Spitzenkandidaten die beiden
Spitzenkandidaten bedeuten mir nichts es
geht wirklich darum wer meiner Meinung
nach die beste Arbeit leisten wird für
die Wirtschaft für die Umwelt und wisst
ihr ich habe viele Leute sagen hören
dass die Wirtschaft natürlich für Sie an
erster Stelle steht aber wer hat die
beste Politik der Physiker könnten white
und die Buchhalterin Erin Kelly haben
2015 advanced symbolics kurz er ist ein
mitbegründet
das Marktforschungsunternehmen nutzt
öffentliche Daten und künstliche
Intelligenz um die Einstellung der
Verbraucher zu prognostizieren wisst ihr
in Zeiten von Cambridge analytica und
all dem denken die Leute dass es sich um
eine Art voodoo-wissenschaft handelt als
ob wir einen Schamanen hätten der Dinge
geschehen lässt ich möchte dass die
Leute verstehen dass es nur um
Mathematik geht Wissenschaft es ist
probabilistisch es ist statistisch so
wie es schon immer war nur dass die
Daten von Pauli und nicht von
Telefonisten erhoben werden sie können
einen ähnlichen Ansatz verwenden um
politische Meinungen vorherzusagen
früher war es schwierig Informationen
über Millionen und Abermillionen von
Menschen zu erhalten und darauf
statistische Physik anzuwenden aber
jetzt habe ich Facebook jetzt habe ich
Twitter wie kann ich das nutzen
obwohl sie weder für politische Parteien
noch für Nachrichtenagenturen Arbeiten
sahen Kelly und White das
wahlvorhersagespiel als eine Möglichkeit
ihre Forschungsmethode zu bewerben
denken Sie daran wie oft wir uns bei der
traditionellen Marktforschung in das
Thema in die Menschen einmischen während
wir sie untersuchen wir müssen uns ein
indem wir sie zu Teilnahme auffordern
wir müssen uns in das Ergebnis ein indem
wir eine Frage stellen und wie wir diese
Frage formulieren unsere Idee war dass
die sozialen Medien eine großartige
Möglichkeit bieten Menschen in ihrer
natürlichen Umgebung zu beobachten und
werden Sie nicht eine viel bessere
Politik und eine viel utopischere
Gesellschaft erreichen wenn Sie genau
wissen was die Menschen in dieser
Gesellschaft wollen
als ich aufwuchs inspirierte mich die
Science Fiction zum Beispiel Asimovs
Foundation Reihe indem man die Physik
und die statistische Physik auf Menschen
und Populationen anwenden und den
gesamten Verlauf der Galaxie abbilden
kann ich war ziemlich enttäuscht als ich
erfuhr dass das nicht wirklich ist
die explosionsartige Zunahme der Daten
in den sozialen Medien bot white eine
potenzielle Fundgrube er konnte
statistische Methoden aus der Physik
anwenden um Daten zu verarbeiten die
anderen als unübersichtlich und
unbrauchbar erscheinen mögen
das war die Geburtsstunde der KI die ASI
Polly nennt
Oliver die Abkürzung für Politik also
haben wir sie einfach so genannt wir
haben uns da keine Gedanken darüber
gemacht außer eben Politik
pauli besteht aus verschiedenen
Bestandteilen kleinen Programm die das
Internet durchforsten und Informationen
sammeln
diese Programme die Algorithmen genannt
werden sind eine Reihe von Anweisungen
zu Durchführung einer bestimmten Aufgabe
sie haben einen Algorithmus der bestimmt
wann sie jemanden auswählen und war
nicht kleiner Algorithmen die diese
Person analysieren und zu dem Schluss
kommen ob die Person männlich oder
weiblich reich oder arm jung oder alt
Schwarz oder Weiß ist
Algorithmen die es uns ermöglichen
Menschen zu finden die über das Thema
sprechen dass wir messen wollen
[Musik]
wenn ich ihnen einen dieser Algorithmen
zeigen würde und wie er funktioniert
würden sie wahrscheinlich sagen das ist
doch ganz einfach
erst wenn man Dutzende und aber dutzende
nimmt und all diese Dinge zusammenfügt
entsteht etwas komplexeres
sie verwendet mehr Daten als ich oder
sie oder so ziemlich jeder hier in einem
Leben verstehen könnte
[Musik]
aber was macht Polly intelligent
beachten Sie dass ich nicht
empfindungsfeld sondern intelligent
gesagt habe richtig sie ist also
intelligent weil sie Konzepte begreifen
kann mathematische Konzepte und weil sie
Muster in Menschen erkennt die wir
selbst nicht sehen können doch diese
Beschreibung bereitet den Kritikern der
KI Unbehagen die ki-methode wirkt auf
Außenstehende wie eine Blackbox sodass
es für nicht ki-experten schwierig ist
das Innenleben der KI oder ihre
Schlussfolgerungen zu hinterfragen
angesichts der Skeptiker sei das
brexit-referendum im Juni 2016 als eine
Möglichkeit ihren Algorithmus zu testen
[Applaus]
die Bürger des Vereinigten Königreichs
stimmten darüber ab ob sie in der
Europäischen Union bleiben oder sie
verlassen wollen
die traditionellen fast täglich
durchgeführten Umfragen zeigten dass das
Land gespalten war je näher der Wahltag
rückte desto klarer wurde dass die
unentschlossenen Wähler wahrscheinlich
über das Schicksal des Landes
entscheiden würden
[Musik]
in der Zwischenzeit hat pauli die
britischen twitter-daten durchforstet um
die Meinungen der Nutzer vorherzusagen
ohne sie direkt zu kontaktieren
Oliver bis drei Tage vor dem
eigentlichen Referendum für den Verbleib
bei uns haben 52 Prozent für den
Verbleib und 48% für den Austritt
gestimmt so wie jeder andere auf der
Welt auch dann kam die Ermordung von Joe
cocks
die Abgeordnete der leberpartei Joe
cocks die sich für den Verbleib im
Parlament eingesetzt hatte wurde am 16
Juni 2016 von einem Rechtsextremisten
erschossen
drei Tage vor dem Referendum waren wir
auf schauen auf Polly und plötzlich will
Großbritannien die EU verlassen das war
etwas anderes als das was sie an jedem
anderen Tag der Woche und während des
gesamten Wahlkampfs gesagt hatte
ich war besorgt denn ein Attentat ist
ein schwarzer Schwan ein schwarzer
Schwan ist ein seltenes Ereignis eines
dass meine KI noch nie zuvor gesehen hat
und bei keiner der Wahlen auf die sie
trainiert hatte gab es ein
attentattentate sind selten wir haben ja
also gesagt sie soll die Ermordung von
Joe cocks ignorieren was ist das
Ergebnis bleiben also testen wir es noch
einmal Joe cocks wird ermordet austreten
was hat sich also geändert was hat sie
gesehen was alle anderen auf der Welt
übersehen haben
das britische Pfund stürzte auf ein
30-jahres-tief und die weltweiten
Aktienmärkte erschütterte die Nachricht
dass die Mehrheit der britischen Wähler
den Austritt aus der Europäischen Union
der zweitgrößten Volkswirtschaft der
Welt wünscht
Polly beobachtet Dinge von denen wir
nicht einmal denken würden dass sie sie
beobachtet wir haben sie nicht darum
gebeten diese Dinge zu beobachten nun
wir sind alles durchgegangen David
Cameron hatte in dieser Zeit viele
Pressekonferenzen gegeben und es gab
eine Sache die er gesagt hatte es ist
richtig dass wir die wahlkampftätigkeit
für dieses Referendum aussetzen und
jedermanns Gedanken sind in dieser
schrecklichen Zeit bei Joes Familie und
bei ihren Wählern während des ganzen
Jahres indem sie die Menschen
beobachtete stellte sie fest dass
Menschen die Online sagten ich denke
darüber nach für einen Austritt zu
stimmen ein Netzwerk von Freunden und
Familienmitgliedern um sich herum hatten
die Ihnen in aller Ruhe erklärten warum
wir für einen Verbleib stimmen sollten
und was die Konsequenzen werden mit der
Zeit gelang es diesem Netzwerk diese
Menschen für den verbleibt zu gewinnen
sofern sie den Dialog aufrecht helfen
aber wenn die Leute nicht mehr
miteinander reden würde einen gewisser
Prozentsatz dieser unentschlossenen auf
der Grundlage dessen was Polly in der
Vergangenheit festgestellt hatte
austreten also wandte sie diesen
Algorithmus an sie hat es genau
getroffen um paulis Methode besser zu
verstehen ist es hilfreich sich
anzuschauen was sie mit traditionellen
Umfragen gemeinsam hat
eine Möglichkeit die öffentliche Meinung
zu erheben sind Befragungen kurze
Interviews werden als Umfragen
bezeichnet einige wenige Personen werden
sorgfältig als Stichproben der
wichtigsten Gruppen der allgemeinen
Öffentlichkeit ausgewählt
jahrzehntelang erreichten die
Meinungsforscher die Menschen
erfolgreich über Festnetzanschlüsse
Direktwerbung oder das Klopfen an Türen
die Rücklaufquote lag bei 80% aller
Anrufe gingen ins Festnetzes gab keine
Handys und die Leute liebten es an
Umfragen teilzunehmen wenn man sich bei
einer Wahl irrt ist das so als würde man
auf seine Boot fahren und das Wasser
verfehlen
das ist das dritte klopfen und im Haus
sitzt dunkel aus ja niemand zu Hause
doch in den letzten 30 Jahren sind die
Nutzung von Festnetzanschlüssen und die
Rücklaufquote von Umfragen stark
zurückgegangen wenn Sie einen
Festnetzanschluss in einem beliebigen
Haus anrufen ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
groß dass sie eine ältere Frau erreichen
Millenials erreichen Sie nicht über das
Festnetz wahrscheinlich werden Sie sie
über Mobiltelefone erreichen oder online
traditionelle Meinungsforscher mussten
ihre Methoden diversifizieren um
verschiedene Zielgruppen zu erreichen
man versucht den politischen Markt den
wichtigen politischen Markt und die
wählende Bevölkerung so genau wie
möglich zu repräsentieren was man also
braucht ist eine gute Abdeckung weil
dieser verschiedenen Bevölkerungsgruppen
und dann versucht man sie in ihrer
Gesamtheit zu betrachten
um die kanadische Bevölkerung im Jahr
2019 zu erfassen kombiniert der
Meinungsforscher Daryl Bricker Umfragen
im Festnetz mit Umfragen per Handy und
Onlineumfragen doch die KI von pauli
geht einen anderen Weg da unsere
Bevölkerung immer vielfältiger wird
brauchen wir eigentlich eine größere
Stichprobe ich meine Kanada ist heute
ganz anders als 1970 oder 1959 als wir
mit der Telefonumfrage begannen aber wir
haben die Wissenschaft seit den 50er
Jahren nicht wirklich weiterentwickelt
wir haben immer noch die gleichen
Stichproben Größen wir gehen immer noch
auf dieselbe Weise an die Wissenschaft
heran auch wenn sich die Bevölkerung
stark verändert hat mit den sozialen
Medien haben wir nun endlich die
Möglichkeit diese Wissenschaft zum
ersten Mal seit 50 Jahren weiter zu
entwickeln
traditionelle Meinung zum Fragen haben
in letzter Zeit mehrere Wahlergebnisse
mit ihren Prognosen verfehlt wir werden
das Weiße Haus gewinnen wir werden es
zurückerobern vielleicht am bekanntesten
bei den US-Präsidentschaftswahlen 2016
sagten die Meinungsforscher mit
überwältigender Mehrheit voraus dass
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump schlagen
würde wenn die Schlangen morgen lang
sind warten sie bitte
[Musik]
Trump Sieg hat gezeigt dass die
Meinungsforscher ihr Ziel verfehlt haben
sie sagten zwar die Volksabstimmung
voraus verpassten aber die Knappen
lokalen Rennen in den Swing States die
Trump einen Sieg im electrol College
bescherten offensichtlich lagen ihre
Modelle einfach völlig daneben der in
den Umfragen vorhergesagte Prozentsatz
der Stimmen ist tatsächlich eingetreten
aber wir haben nicht das Elektro College
gemessen
natürlich ist das ein Albtraum wenn so
etwas passiert
während es zu kostspielig und
ineffizient wäre regelmäßig große
Befragungen mit herkömmlichen Methoden
durchzuführen ist dies dank der enormen
Reichweite der sozialen Medien mit Hilfe
von Kai möglich in den sozialen Medien
über Politik zu sprechen oder alle
Meinungen in den sozialen Medien zu
äußern ist heute so etwas wie die Norm
das ist zu einer normalen Art der
Kommunikation geworden so wie die Leute
früher auch häufig lange Gespräche am
Telefon geführt haben natürlich konnte
man früher nicht einfach die Telefone
der Leute Abhören man musste sie anrufen
und nach ihrer Meinung fragen aber jetzt
ist das interessante an den sozialen
Medien dass die Leute ihre Meinung über
die sozialen Medien mitteilen oft tun
sie das in einer Form die öffentlich ist
und die es uns ermöglicht zu sehen was
sie sagen und daraus ihre Meinung
abzuleiten aber nicht alles Social Media
Plattformen verfügen über Daten die für
weiter relevant sind
wir verwenden je nach Problem dass wir
untersuchen wollen eine andere
Datenquelle für die Stichproben wir
haben festgestellt dass wir bei Wahlen
das stärkste Signal von Twitter erhalten
viele Meinungsforscher und
Sozialwissenschaftler stellen den Wert
von twitter-daten in Frage
Plattformen wie Twitter oder Facebook
sind im Grunde eine Gruppe selbst
gewählter Menschen wenn nicht alle
Kanadier sind in den sozialen Medien
aktiv und selbst wenn Sie in den
sozialen Medien sind nutzen nicht alle
von ihnen diese um über Politik zu
diskutieren im Grunde genommen erhalten
Sie also einen Ausschnitt aus einem
kleineren Teil der Öffentlichkeit
ich glaube 12 bis 15 Prozent nutzen
Twitter für Nachrichten 20% nutzen
Twitter im allgemeinen ich denke dabei
eher an Eliten Journalisten und hoch
engagierte Super-User die auf Twitter
sind
es ist also nicht jeder auf Twitter
nehmen wir die niedrige Zahl von 17
Prozent die immer noch viel größer ist
als die derzeitigen 9% oder weniger die
man über Anrufe erreicht 17 % eines
Landes mit 36 Millionen Einwohnern sind
etwa 7 Millionen Menschen zu denen wir
Zugang haben
white glaubt dass eine KI die große aber
typischerweise Junge unter Banane
Nutzerbasis von Twitter in Kanada durch
Forsten und dennoch Prognosen erstellen
kann die für die gesamte Bevölkerung
repräsentativ sind
es sind weniger als drei Wochen bis zum
Wahltag und ich weiß dass ihr Wahlsystem
mit künstlicher Intelligenz irgendwann
zu einer Schlussfolgerung darüber kommt
was ihrer Meinung nach am 21 Oktober
passieren wird es ist noch zu früh
nämlich an es ist noch zu früh was Herrn
truido Gutes verheißt ist die Tatsache
dass die Liberalen seit Beginn des
Wahlkampfes durchweg auf dem ersten
Platz liegen der erste Platz in der
Volksabstimmung oder Gesamtabstimmung
oder bei der Anzahl der Sitze Sitzplätze
wir machen das in jedem einzelnen
Wahlkreis und das macht wie wir bei den
Wahlen in und terio gesehen haben einen
großen Unterschied weil man in der
Gesamtzahl der Stimme und in den
Umfragen vorne liegt bedeutet das noch
kein sie ganz genau weil die Effizienz
der Stimmabgabe in einem first Pest der
Post System am wichtigsten ist
wenn man mit den meisten Menschen
spricht die mit Daten von vielen
Menschen arbeiten sagen sie dass sie
alles sammeln wollen was sie können
alles was jeder auf Facebook und Twitter
und redet sagt und auf alles schauen
wollen
die meisten Kritiker gehen davon aus
dass asi aus dem sogenannten
twitter-firehost dem vollständigen
Datenstream schöpfen muss in diesem Fall
bräuchte white eine Möglichkeit die
riesige Menge an Echtzeit Daten zu
filtern und nur die Daten zusammen die
für die wahlvorhersage nützlich sind
angesichts der Größe der Herausforderung
bestreiten Kritiker die optimistischen
Behauptungen von White
wenn ich jetzt nur diesen fire Hose
anzapfe und den Datenstrom einfließen
lasse erhalte ich ein sehr verzerrtes
Bild
deshalb zählen wir nicht die Tweets
sondern die Menschen
unsere große Idee ist dass das was die
Meinungsforscher gemacht haben
funktioniert das ist die geheime Zutat
wir nehmen wirklich sehr gute
Stichproben von Menschen
mit anderen Worten anstatt zu versuchen
im twitter-fire-haus auszusortieren
behauptet weiter habe einen Weg gefunden
ihn zu umgehen bevor pauli echte Daten
erhebt stellt Polly zunächst eine
repräsentative Stichprobe zusammen
genau wie Meinungsforscher
diejenigen die sagen dass man sich die
sozialen Medien ansehen kann um ein Bild
davon zu bekommen was auf der Ebene der
Rider passiert das ist ein interessantes
Konzept dem wir sicherlich nachgehen
werden würde ich darauf wetten dass ich
morgen eine Wahl durchführen kann bei
der ich jede einzelne Region auf der
Grundlage der sozialen Medien richtig
Vorhersage nein
zuallererst die Rückverfolgung von
Personen bis zu dem Bezirken schwierig
es ist schwierig herauszufinden von wo
aus dieser Account getwittert hat sie
kennen doch den alten Witz das im
Internet niemand weiß dass sie ein Hund
sind nun bei Twitter weiß niemand ob man
ich China Russland oder hier in Toronto
ist es ist sehr schwierig zu sagen ja
dieses Konto kommt ganz sicher aus
Kanada
eine repräsentative Stichprobe von
kanadien muss aus tatsächlichen kanadien
bestehen white mind er könne bestätigen
dass seine Twitter-Nutzer legitim sind
wir verwenden Informationen die die
Nutzer in Ihrem Konto hinterlegen wir
sehen dass sie in Kanada sind gut sie
sagen ich bin in Kanada also überprüfen
wir das der erste Test ist sind die
meisten ihrer Freunde auch in Kanada
sehen sie sich ihre Historie an sehen
Sie sich an worüber sie sprechen wenn
sie Kanadier sind reden sie
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen über
Eishockey oder andere kanadische Dinge
vielleicht reden sie über das kalte
Wetter
für meinungsvorschau ist deine
Stichprobe nur dann repräsentativ und
zufällig wenn jedes Mitglied die gleiche
Chance hat in der Stichprobe
aufzutauchen
[Musik]
stell dir vor du hättest eine große
Schüssel mit Jelly Beans
und da wären rote blaue grüne und gelbe
du brauchst nicht jeder einzelne Jelly
Bean zu zählen um herauszufinden dass es
rote grüne gelbe und die anderen Farben
gibt wenn Sie alle gleichmäßig über die
ganze große Schüssel verteilt sind
wenn du deine Hand hinein steckst sie
herausziehst und die Jelly Beans
hinlegst solltest du eine Vorstellung
davon bekommen was ich in der Schale
befindet wenn du das zehnmal tust dann
hast du eine ziemlich gute Vorstellung
davon was in dieser Schale ist nicht
weil die Schüssel kleiner wird sondern
weil die Proben gleichmäßig werden darum
geht es bei der Probenahme also wirklich
in der Vergangenheit haben
Meinungsforscher die Befragten durch
zufällige Auswahl von Namen aus einem
Telefonbuch ermittelt in der digitalen
Welt erfordert die zufällige und
repräsentative Stichprobe ein anderes
Paradigma
es gibt ein Spiel das heißt six degrees
of Kevin Bacon das heißt ich suche mir
einen Filmschauspieler aus und versuche
ihnen sechs Schritten mit Kevin Bacon zu
verbinden und das gleiche Spiel kann man
auch auf Facebook und Twitter spielen
man kann sich eine beliebige Person oder
einen Promi aussuchen und verfolgen wie
man selbst mit ihm verbunden ist und im
Durchschnitt über drei bis vier Ecken
Verbindungen zu jedem Menschen auf der
Welt Herstellen
der Polly Algorithmus verwendet eine
mathematische Formel um ein
durchschnittliches Minimum an Sprüngen
zwischen den gesammelten Twitter-Nutzern
zu garantieren auf diese Weise werden
der virtuelle Abstand und die
Zufälligkeit zwischen den Nutzern
definiert aber kritiker argumentieren
dass dies immer noch nicht die mangelnde
Vielfalt unter den Twitternutzern löst
ich kann diese Voreingenommenheit bei
Twitter berücksichtigen ich mache es so
dass ich sage so sieht die Volkszählung
aus so sollte meine Verteilung sein und
im Algorithmus steht wenn sie zu sehr
von dem abweicht was man erwartet dann
muss man so lange warten bis es sich
angleicht wenn ich also zum Beispiel
sehe dass meine Stichprobe bei jungen
Männern aus der Stadt etwas einseitig
ist höre ich einfach auf junge Männer
aus der Stadt zusammen mache eine Pause
und füge keine weiteren in meine
Stichprobe ein bis sich ältere Frauen
aus dem ländlichen Raum erhalte
die Stichprobe von Polly entspricht also
nicht der Mehrheit der Twitter-Nutzer
sondern ist auf eine Mischung von
Nutzern beschränkt die der tatsächlichen
Demografie der einzelnen Rider
entspricht white behauptet damit werde
das behoben was Kritiker als tragischen
Fehler in Pollys Hauptdaten Quelle
ansehen
und das ist der schlüsselalgorithmus
hinter pauli
wenn es jemals eine Bombe in einem
kanadischen Wahlkampf gegeben hat dann
war es diese Woche Fotos von Justin
trudo mit Schwarz geschminktem Gesicht
wirbelten ein sehr kompliziertes Gebräu
von Meinungen im Land auf Erin Kelly was
sagt pauli zu den Auswirkungen dieser
ganzen Sache das war eine große Bombe
Polizei also wie die Zahlen von Mister
trido die Anzahl der Sitzer gestern um
25 sitze viel heute morgen hatte sich
wieder erholt er hat fünf Sätze
hinzugewonnen hat also netto 20 Sitze
verloren aber das hat ihnen von der
Mehrheit in die Minderheit gebracht
der Vorsitzende der NDP war gestern der
größte Gewinner die haben gesehen wie
seine Umfragewerte gestiegen sind er hat
also wirklich dadurch glänzen können wie
also kommt ein Algorithmus von Tweet zu
einer Prognose über einen Rückgang der
Sitze
was bedeutet eigentlich ein Tweet und
was bedeutet es wenn wir tweeten wir
wissen dass die Leute im Internet Witze
machen sie sind ironisch die Menschen
teilen immer mehr Bilder und das schafft
Herausforderungen schwieriger zu
interpretieren sind means also diese
Grafiken die oft Anspielungen auf die
Popkultur enthalten ich weiß also nicht
immer was da los ist und dann denke ich
wenn ich das nicht verstehe mit meiner
Rechenleistung obwohl ich ein lebender
atmender Mensch bin was ist denn mit
diesem armen Computer der das alles
verstehen muss
laut white versucht pauli gar nicht die
Bedeutung von Tweet zu interpretieren
[Musik]
bei meinen ersten Versuchen
Wahlprognosen zu erstellen habe ich die
Experimente durchgeführt und immer
wieder stellte ich fest dass einfach
Erwähnungen die positive oder negative
Stimmung jedes Mal übertrafen
Polly verfolgt den Prozentsatz der
Nutzer in der Stichprobe die jede
Bundespartei erwähnen dann vergleicht
die KI diese Ergebnisse mit historischen
meinungsmustern am Tag nach dem bekannt
werden der Black face Story stieg die
Zahl der Nennung in der liberalen Partei
im Vergleich zu den anderen Parteien
sprunghaft an ohne die Bedeutung dieser
Tweet zu verstehen interpretiert pauli
diese Änderungen in den Erwähnungen als
einen Rückgang der prognostizierten
Sitze für die Liberalen ich denke dass
diese Umfragen interessant sind weil sie
einen Punkt in der Vergangenheit
darstellen richtig sie sagen nicht die
Zukunft voraus sie sind eine
Momentaufnahme von der man einen
Eindruck davon bekommt wie die
Öffentlichkeit denkt die KI sammelt
ständig Daten dadurch lassen sich im
Vergleich zu weniger häufig
durchgeführten Umfragen im Laufe der
Zeit musste in der Nutzeraktivität
erkennen
eines der größten und schwierigsten
Probleme von echtzeiterhebungen ist dass
man sieht dass gerade etwas Gutes oder
Schlechtes geschieht und man denkt sich
das ist ein Teil der Daten aber dann
muss man einen weiteren Tag abwarten um
erkennen zu können ob die Entwicklung
real ist oder nur ein Ausreißer war und
dann fragt man sich immer wie viele
Punkte ein Trend ausmachen ob es einer
ist wahrscheinlich nicht sind es zwei
vielleicht drei Jahr vier vier auf jeden
Fall aber weiß mal wo der Punkt ist um
einen Trend zu erkennen sie pauli
öffentliche Umfragen als Referenzpunkt
daran sie analysiert Muster des Nutzer
Engagements immer wenn Ihre ausgewählten
Twitter-Nutzer politische Parteien
erwähnen dann vergleicht sie das
Engagement mit den Umfrageergebnissen
der einzelnen Parteien auf der Grundlage
dieser Beziehungen kann Polly
vorhersagen ob Ihre Daten auf einen
stabilen Trend hindeuten oder nicht
sometimes manchmal sind diese Menschen
über etwas wütend über ein Thema und sie
sind vielleicht in einem bestimmten
Moment wütend darüber aber Polly ist in
der Lage auf sehr unvoreingenommene
Weise durch diese Wut hindurch zu sehen
und zu sagen wie lange wird die
Bevölkerung brauchen um über diese Wut
und diesen Schmerz hinwegzukommen und
wird das bis zum Wahltag
Reichenau kontinuierlich diesen
kontinuierlichen Strom von Aktivitäten
bezeichnet man als Längsschnitt Daten
durch die Untersuchung von Daten auf
dieser Weise kann Polly Muster im
Zeitverlauf erkennen und sie mit der
aktuellen Aktivität vergleichen das
bedeutet auch dass Poly die Daten in der
Zeit zurückverfolgen kann um
unerforschte Trends neu zu untersuchen
vor dem blackfacing Skandal gab es
glaube ich kein einziges
Meinungsforschungsinstitut dass die
Frage gestellt hätte ob sich ihre
Meinung ändern würde wenn sie einen
Parteivorsitzenden in einem fragwürdigen
Kostüm in seinen Zwanzigern sehen
ich glaube nicht dass jemand daran
gedacht hat diese Frage zu stellen
das wunderbare am Polly und den
Längsschnittstudien ist dass sich
zurückgehen und genau messen kann wie
sie vor einer Woche oder einem Monat
gedacht haben und das ist etwas was man
nicht eine oder zwei Wochen später durch
eine Frage erreichen kann
ich würde vermuten dass die Kanadier
sich vielleicht nicht so sehr für
blackfacing interessieren wie Sie es in
den sozialen Medien behaupten es gab
eine Menge Empörung und ich würde es
sogar als aufgesetzte Empörung
bezeichnen insbesondere in den sozialen
Medien wo es hieß oh mein Gott ich kann
das nicht glauben
wirklich sie können das nicht glauben du
kannst nicht glauben dass ein reicher
weißer Typ ausgebeck ein schwarzes
Gesicht auf einer noblen Privatschule
trägt die eine Party unter dem Motto
arabische Nächte veranstaltet ich meine
die Party an und für sich auch ohne das
schwarze Gesicht war rassistisch
[Musik]
wenn man bedenkt wie gewaltig diese
Geschichte wahr als sie vor anderthalb
Wochen aufkam ist sie praktisch ich will
nicht sagen aus den Medien verschwunden
aber man sieht jetzt so wenige Hinweise
darauf ist diese Geschichte im
Wesentlichen vorbei so weit sie das aus
ihren Umfragen erschließen können wenn
die anderen Parteien das immer wieder
zur Sprache bringen ist es zu dem
Zeitpunkt absolute Kraftverschwendung
ich denke er erholt sich und die
langsame Erholung könnte auf eine Reihe
von Problemen zurückzuführen sein und
nicht nur auf das blackfacing hat mit
seinen ersten Aussagen nach dem Black
face Skandal viele Menschen beeindruckt
der Wille war da war wie in verschenkt
nun er hat zwei Sitze mehr als vor der
Blackface waren aber das ist ein
Rückgang gegenüber den neuen sitzen die
er vorher gewonnen hat es fängt also an
sich abzuschwächen
Begriffe wie künstliche Intelligenz und
maschinelles Lernen werden manchmal auf
unterschiedliche Weise verwendet um
verschiedene Arten von magischen Dingen
über Computer zu malen die so denken wie
Menschen
die moderne Bedeutung besteht im
wesentlichen darin dass es sich um sehr
ausgeklügelte und sehr flexible
Algorithmen handelt die es uns
ermöglichen sehr große Datenmengen mit
sehr komplizierten Beziehungen zwischen
ihnen zu verarbeiten und sehr flexible
Modelle zu entwickeln die es den
Computer ermöglichen unwahrscheinliche
Beziehungen herzustellen
warum ist sie KI warum ist sie nicht nur
eine Statistik oder eine Sammlung von
Codes der Unterschied besteht darin dass
sie in der Lage ist dies größtenteils
selbstständig zu tun ich muss nicht
reingehen und eine Regel aufstellen und
sagen Polly wenn du das siehst dann mach
das sie ist in der Lage die Dinge selbst
herauszufinden
Lernfähigkeit ist die Grundlage dafür
wie sie zukünftige Wahlergebnisse
vorhersagt der Schlüssel zum
maschinellen lernen ist ein Prozess der
als Training eines statistischen Modells
bekannt ist wenn wir über das Trainieren
eines Modells sprechen meinen wir dass
wir einige Daten haben deren Antwort wir
bereits kennen vielleicht geht es darum
wie die Leute bei der letzten Wahl
gewählt haben oder vielleicht geht es
darum wie viele Menschen Waffen gekauft
oder nicht gekauft haben aber wir kennen
die Antwort bereits und dann ziehen wir
Schlüsse daraus und sagen okay es
scheint es Männer die hier wohnen eher
diese Person wählen oder dass Männer die
diese Zeitschrift abonniert haben eher
eine Waffe kaufen wir lernen diese
Zusammenhänge und schauen ob unser
Modell das auch vorherigen Daten
trainiert wurde vorhersagen kann was als
nächstes passiert pauli untersucht Daten
aus vergangenen Wahlen wie von 20 15 sie
findet Muster zwischen der Art und Weise
wie sich die Menschen auf Twitter
engagieren und der Art und Weise wie sie
bei dieser Wahl tatsächlich abstimmen
das Modell drückt all diese Beziehungen
als mathematische Wahrscheinlichkeit aus
anschließend sagte vorher wie sich die
Wähler in den einzelnen Wahlkreisen im
Jahr 2019 höchstwahrscheinlich verhalten
werden
[Musik]
wir beginnen mit sagen wir ich versuche
zu erklären wie die Flüssigkeit in
diesem Becher funktioniert ich beginne
mit einem Haufen von Wassermolekülen ich
habe ich weiß nicht Milliarden Billionen
gigantillionen zitieren Sie mich nicht
eine Menge Wassermoleküle sie prallen
aneinander ab aber in diesem Wasserglas
interessiert es niemanden was all die
Moleküle tun oder das Interessante ist
was passiert wenn ich das Wasser in das
Glas gieße was macht das Wasser wenn ich
mein Glas so schüttelt wie bewegt sich
das Wasser und das kann man in der
Physik herausfinden denn obwohl es eine
Billion Wassermoleküle gibt haben wir
diese Theorien die besagen dass wir wenn
es genug Wassermoleküle gibt statistisch
herausfinden können wie sie sich alle
zusammen bewegen um eine Art
Beschreibung dafür zu erhalten wie
dieses große makroskopische System also
das Wasser in diesem Glas tatsächlich
funktioniert die öffentliche Meinung ist
im Grunde genommen dasselbe wir haben
viele viele Menschen jeder hat seine
eigene Meinung und es ist ziemlich
schwierig die Meinung einer einzelnen
Person vorherzusagen die Menschen sind
chaotisch sie ändern ihre Meinung wegen
diesem oder Jen aber wenn man genug
Leute zusammenbringt kann man sie
statistisch als eine Sache modellieren
und selbst wenn Joe seine Meinung morgen
drastisch ändern könnte und Sarah sich
um eine wirklich seltsame Sache kümmert
und ihre Meinung ändert kann man sich
statistisch annähern und ein Gefühl
dafür bekommen wohin die Gesamtmeinung
der Bevölkerung geht in gewisser Weise
machen wir also etwas ganz ähnliches wie
in der Physik wo wir ständig
herausfinden wollen wie all diese Atome
oder Moleküle oder was auch immer
zusammen wirken und wir wenden das jetzt
einfach auf Menschen an wir halten uns
alle gerne für einzigartige wüstenblumen
und das sind wir auch wirklich aber das
schöne an der statistischen Mathematik
ist dass wir wenn wir genug von uns
zusammen haben tatsächlich vernünftige
Vorhersagen darüber machen können wie
sich die Meinungen der Menschen im
Durchschnitt bilden werden
unabhängig davon wie ausgefallen das
Modell ist die Achillesferse der
wahlvorhersagen ist die Frage ob die
Menschen tatsächlich zur Wahl ohne gehen
werden wenn ich Wahlumfragen durchführe
habe ich immer Angst denn der Ruf der
Firma steht auf dem Spiel und der
persönliche Ruf steht auf dem Spiel was
habe ich verpasst was habe ich übersehen
was habe ich verpasst wie könnte ich
falsch liegen wie könnte ich mich irren
oft verbrennt man sich die Finger es
gibt sechs oder sieben Parteien oder wie
viele Mann auch immer nennen mag die in
diesem Wahlkampf in jedem Wahlbezirk
antreten und dann gibt es noch eine
Partei die nicht auf dem Wahlzettel
steht die aber wirklich wichtig ist und
die nennt sich die attraktiv Partei das
ist ein Problem für traditionelle
Meinungsforscher denn ihre Vorhersagen
beruhen auf der Wahlbeteiligung in der
Vergangenheit
jeder sagt natürlich gehe ich hier ich
meine die Zahl der Menschen die sagen
ich gehe nicht wählen das ist mir egal
ist winzig im Vergleich zu der Zeit
derer die tatsächlich nicht wählen das
zusammen mit der Tatsache dass Menschen
die sich nicht genug für Politik
interessieren und zu wählen
höchstwahrscheinlich auch nicht an die
Tür gehen und lange Gespräche mit einem
akquisitor führen oder einen Anruf zur
Meinungsumfrage beantworten oder ihre
Ansichten über Politiker Twitter
veröffentlichen nicht Wähler schließen
sich also in vielerlei Hinsicht selbst
aus dem Gespräch aus was ist schwieriger
macht sie zu finden und zu verstehen und
damit auch schwieriger vorherzusagen wie
viele es sein werden kann
im Gegensatz dazu basiert die Methode
von Polly auf den unterstützungsmustern
auf lokaler Ebene und ist weniger
anfällig für die nationale
Wahlbeteiligung
in philosophischer Hinsicht sehen einige
Kritiker immer noch ein Problem Polly
sagt auf der Grundlage statistischer
Korrelationen wahrscheinlicher
sitzplatzergebnisse voraus aber sie
erklärt nicht warum etwas passiert wir
werden mit den Pipelines weitermachen
denn es wurde sehr viel darüber
diskutiert ein Beispiel nach den beiden
französischsprachigen Debatten Anfang
Oktober verzeichnete pauli einen Anstieg
der Unterstützung für den Block hier weg
war aber keine Ursache Mister Trudy sind
sie gegen eine Pipeline oder nicht das
ist Teil eines Prozesses für den wir die
Zustimmung der Gemeinden und der
indigenen Völker benötigen werden sie
geweckt sagen dass es keine geben wird
das ist der Grund warum ich die Idee
eines energiekorridors vorgebracht habe
Polis Betreuer haben einen Grund für die
Beule ausgemacht in Tweets aus Gebäck
entdeckten sie einen Anstieg des
Schlüsselwortes Pipeline bei den Leuten
die den Block hier weg war unterstützen
sehen wir dass sie keine Pipeline wollen
weil sie sagen dass Kinder grüne Energie
hat warum nehmen wir also nicht die
grüne Energie aus Queck und verkaufen
sie an anstatt die schmutzige Energie
aus Alberta zu kaufen einige Experten
wie die Journalistin Chantal Eber sahen
die Debatte anders ich würde sagen dass
Schiers Auftritt der schlechteste
Auftritt eines Bewerbers und das Amt des
Premierministers war den ich seit
Jahrzehnten in einer
französischsprachigen Debatte gesehen
habe schier hat also den Wahlkampf in
Gepäck verloren nicht nur weil der Block
gewonnen hat es geht auch darum dass er
nicht den richtigen Eindruck gemacht hat
während der Bär ihre Erfahrung nutzt um
den Wandel der Unterstützungen cabag zu
erklären ist Kellys Erklärung auch eine
menschliche Interpretation Polys Daten
weisen lediglich auf eine Korrelation
zwischen den zugewinnen des Blocks und
den Begriff Pipeline hin nicht auf eine
Ursache
[Musik]
heute ist also freitag der 18 oktober
also drei Tage vor der Wahl ein Freitag
die Wahl ist am Montag wir werden in
einer halben Stunde auf Sendung gehen
wir haben die Zahlen noch einmal
überprüft denn in der letzten
Pressemitteilung die wir gestern
verschickt haben sagten wir dass es mit
einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von 66% einer
liberale Minderheitsregierung geben wird
und heute morgen sagt Polly die
Wahrscheinlichkeit liege bei 77%. jetzt
wird Polly von Tag zu Tag deutlicher je
näher die Menschen eine endgültigen
Entscheidung kommen ich mache mir jedes
mal Sorgen wenn ich auf Sendung gehe
dass ich das Ergebnis beeinflussen
könnte wenn ich sage dass pauli das so
sieht dass die Leute ihre Meinung
aufgrund der neuesten Informationen
ändern werden ich denke dass wir Beweise
dafür sind
schon vor Polly stellten Sozialforscher
sich die Frage ob die Veröffentlichung
von Umfrageergebnissen während eines
Wahlkampfes die Meinung widerspiegeln
oder sogar beeinflussen manche sagen
dass diese Frage durch das größere
Ausmaß der KI noch dringlicher geworden
ist
ich denke dass Mythos der Neutralität im
Bezug auf den politischen Prozess auf
die Probe stellt sowohl die Neutralität
von Journalisten als auch die
Neutralität von Meinungsforschern
einerseits nutzen die Parteien Umfragen
und Technologien um zu entscheiden was
sie tun werden andererseits nutzen die
medienumfragen und Vorhersagen um ein
Gefühl dafür zu bekommen was passiert
und das ist eine Rückkopplungsschleife
richtig es spielt keine Rolle ob man
sich innerhalb oder außerhalb des
Prozesses befindet die Wahrnehmung der
Zukunft bestimmt die Zukunft wenn also
die Medien anfangen zu sagen dass die
NDP keine Chance hat wird die NDP
anfangen zu denken dass sie keine Chance
hat es geht also wirklich um den
Einfluss den Vorhersagen darauf haben
wie wir die Zukunft behandeln und ich
denke in dieser Hinsicht spielt es keine
Rolle ob es sich um eine Partei die
Medien oder ein einzelnes
Meinungsforschungsinstitut handelt die
Veröffentlichung dieser Vorhersagen
beeinflusst die Öffentlichkeit und somit
auch das Ergebnis
der Tag der Entscheidung ist Montag die
meisten Umfragen deuten Prozent
Gleichstand zwischen den Liberalen und
den konservativen hin hat Polly der
Algorithmus der künstlichen Intelligenz
eine genauere Vorstellung von dem was
auch von zukommt finden wir es heraus
sie haben keine Ahnung wie viele Leute
diese Woche zu mir kam sagten was sagt
pauli sie tragen nicht grundlos rot ja
ich habe diese Farben absichtlich
gewählt wegen dem was Polly und erzählt
das ist eine liberale Regierung sein
wird eine liberale Minderheitsregierung
eine liberale Minderheitsregierung
bedeutet das dass sie bereit sind diese
Wahl endgültig zu entscheiden nun es ist
interessant oder 77% sind stark aber
nicht so stark wie wir es gerne sehen
würden es ist nicht so stark wie zu
diesem Zeitpunkt im Jahr 2015 als wir in
der Lage waren die Wahl einen Monat
früher zu benennen die Wählerschaft ist
dieses Mal viel weniger entschlossen
dort am unteren Ende des Diagramms ist
eine beträchtliche Anzahl von
Wahlkreisen die noch
mehr als 20 Wahlkreise in der Provinz
sind noch unentschieden ich fühle mich
verpflichtet darauf hinzuweisen dass bei
den letzten nationalen Wahlen in den
Vereinigten Staaten wissen Sie alle
diese Trecker sagten dass Hillary
Clinton eine 80 richtige Chance hätte
die Wahl zu gewinnen und das hat sie
nicht bei 80 sie haben die Liberalen auf
77 das ist noch nicht vorbei nämlich an
nein das ist es nicht der Unterschied
zwischen Hilary und diesen Ergebnis ist
dass wir jeden einzelnen sitzzellen wir
sehen also dass die Liberalen und die
Konservativen bei den Volksabstimmungen
landesweit gleich auflegen aber wenn es
um die Sitze geht fängt es an
interessant zu werden da man hier
aufgrund unseres Systems eine Kluft
sieht es kommt also darauf an wie sich
das Ergebnis der Volksabstimmung auf der
einzelnen Sitze auswirkt
[Musik]
es ist Wahl nach 2019 fast 18 Millionen
Kanadier haben ihre Stimme abgegeben
einschließlich der vorgezogenen
Wahlgänge
das entspricht eine Wahlbeteiligung von
66% die um einige Prozent höher ist als
erwartet
die Liberalen bilden der Regierung aber
die Konservativen gewinnen die
Volksabstimmung Tage später ist es an
der Zeit die tatsächlichen Ergebnisse
mit den sitzprognosen zu vergleichen die
Wahl 2019 endete diese Woche natürlich
mit einer liberalen Minderheitsregierung
das ist die nationale sitzprognose die
sie uns gegeben haben die die Liberalen
in einer Spanne zwischen 116 und 173
aber im Wesentlichen bei 145 die Tories
bei 123 die NDP bei 48 den Block bei 46
und die Grünen irgendwo zwischen 1 und 5
zeigt möglicherweise ein paar
unabhängige und einer von der
Volkspartei jetzt drehen wir das um und
das ist die nationale sitzprognose am
Sonntag die letzte war also am Samstag
diese ist vom Sonntag den tag vor der
Wahl und Sie können sehen dass sich die
Dinge geändert haben die Liberalen
liegen jetzt bei 155 Tutorials bei 18
und dann kommen wir zum Montag und das
sind die tatsächlichen Wahlergebnisse
100 157 Sitze für die Liberalen 121 für
die Konservativen 32 für den Block 24
für die neuen Demokraten 3 für die
Grünen eine für George Wilson und keiner
für die Volkspartei sie würden sie die
Genauigkeit charakterisieren mit der
Polly ihren Job gemacht hat
wenn sie beurteilen wollen wie gut
jemand deine Wahl vorausgesagt hat ist
es meiner Meinung nach am fairsten ihn
mit anderen Personen zu vergleichen die
versucht haben die Wahl vorauszusagen
wenn ein Unternehmen besser abschneidet
als alle anderen dann ist das
wahrscheinlich ein ziemlich gutes
Ergebnis
am Tag vor der Wahl sagten einige
traditionelle Meinungsforscher nur das
Ergebnis der Volksabstimmung voraus
andere waren ebenfalls bereit eine
liberale Minderheit vorherzusagen aber
nur wenige sagten öffentlich eine
geringe Anzahl von sitzen voraus das
Meinungsforschungsinstitut three hundred
thirty eight Canada hat das Ergebnis von
299 der 338 Wahlkreise richtig
vorhergesagt laut advanced symbolics hat
pauli 38 richtig vorausgesagt
war diese Wahl wirklich so leicht
vorherzusagen
es war nicht leicht die Wahl
vorherzusagen aber sie war vorhersehbar
oder ich finde es interessant weil alle
gesagt haben dass es so knapp war
deshalb kann man sich die Sitzverteilung
und die Wahlkreise ansehen das ist fast
schon eine Notwendigkeit wenn man
Umfragen machen will wir haben das
zuerst bei der trump-wahl in den USA
gesehen und das hat sich fortgesetzt es
scheint dass die Wahlen immer enger
werden und wenn es sich um eine
Minderheitsregierung handelt ist es
natürlich etwas schwieriger zu sagen
aber für pollywise konsistent dass Sie
immer einen Sieg der Liberalen sah
wenn man sich unsere Wahlergebnisse
ansieht haben wir bei der Wahl 2019
wirklich gut abgeschnitten aber es gab
auch einige Wahlkreise die wir verloren
haben es läuft darauf hinaus dass wir
davon ausgehen dass alle Parteien am
letzten Wochenende vor der Wahl in allen
Wahlkreisen in denen sie eine Chance
haben könnten den gleichen Wahlkampf
führen
mich wahrscheinlich gerade aus denn es
hat sich herausgestellt dass das nicht
stimmt es hat sich herausgestellt dass
politische Parteien Wahlkreise auswählen
die sie strategisch gewinnen wollen und
wir haben das alles nicht berücksichtigt
deshalb würde ich gerne einen wirklich
offenen Dialog mit den Leuten führen die
sich in der Politikwissenschaft
auskennen
[Musik]
sowohl white als auch Kelly behaupten
stolz dass paulis endgültige
sitzvorhersage genauer war als die der
meisten etablierten Meinungsforscher
obwohl white einräumt dass es asi ein
Fachwissen über die Funktionsweise von
kampagnenmangelt für Kritiker einer
ki-methode offenbart dieses
Eingeständnis einige naive und
schädliche politische Annahmen für die
Befürworter ist die relative Genauigkeit
von Polly bei der sitzplatzprognose
jedoch ein vielversprechendes Beispiel
für KI
immer wenn ich Leute sagen höre ich habe
das Ding ich mich zurück und sage okay
du hast das Ding nun wissen Sie die
großen börsennotierten
Forschungsunternehmen die mehr Geld
haben um diese Art von Singen zu tun als
jeder andere ganz zu schweigen von den
Googles und den Facebooks und den
Twitters und all diesen anderen Leuten
die all das Geld und all die besten
Daten Wissenschaftler haben die an
dieser Art von Dingen arbeiten sie
können diese Vorhersagen auf der
Grundlage ihrer Plattform nicht treffen
erfahrene Meinungsforscher und
Statistiker fordern immer noch mehr
Beweise sie bezweifeln weiterhin den
Wert von Twitter als primäre Datenquelle
und sie bestehen darauf dass pauli eine
viel längere Erfolgsbilanz bei der
Vorhersage von Wahlen vorweisen kann
bevor sie zugeben dass diese Methode
seriös und genau ist
es gibt eine gängige Redewendung die als
Haftungsausschluss beim Kauf von
Produkten und so weiter verwendet wird
und die besagt des vergangene Leistungen
keine Indikator für zukünftige
Leistungen sind und ich denke das gilt
auch für Vorhersage Algorithmen denn
wenn sie bei den letzten Wahlen gut
abgeschnitten haben dann spricht das
zwar für sie ist aber noch keine
Garantie und je besser Sie bei immer
mehr Wahlen abschneiden desto mehr
vertrauen kann man ihnen entgegen
bringen
laut Alisa wird Pollys Prognose Modell
mit mehr wahldaten immer besser werden
und mit dem Input von
Sozialwissenschaftlern um ihre
Algorithmen zu verfeinern
wir haben einen langen Weg zurückgelegt
um dahin zu kommen wo KI heute ist und
vieles was der KI geholfen hat dorthin
zu gelangen wo sie heute steht ist dass
es mit dem Internet eine Explosion von
Daten gibt die Explosion der
öffentlichen Daten birgt auch Risiken
soziale Medien sind kostenlos wenn man
dafür seine Privatsphäre aufgibt
persönliche Daten stehen dann
vermarketing-zwecke zur Verfügung
Kritiker waren auch davor dass die
Plattformen die Daten gegen ihre eigene
Nutzer verwenden indem sie die Plattform
sucht erregender machen
als das Auto auf den Markt kam gab es
weder Sicherheitsgurte noch Airbags aber
als wir entdeckten das diese Autos in
Unfälle verwickelt werden und Menschen
überfahren können begannen wir bessere
Bremsen Airbags und Sicherheitsgurte zu
fordern
in den ersten 10 15 Jahren der sozialen
Medien lautete das Argument legen wir
diesen Unternehmen keine Handschellen an
denn wir wollen sehen wo und was Sie tun
können und wie sie der Gesellschaft
helfen können aber jetzt entdecken wir
all die Autounfälle die entdecken all
die Schäden diese anrichten können und
ich denke dass wir in den nächsten
Jahren darüber diskutieren werden wie
eine Regulierung der sozialen Medien
aussehen kann
ich denke das große Problem ist dass wir
den Wahlkampf in einer analogen Welt
sehen obwohl er ein Wirklichkeit
automatisiert und digitale ist und weder
unsere Sprache noch unsere Gesetze sind
wirklich die Macht vor die
facebook-karte und die Art und Weise in
der Einzelperson oder politische
Parteien oder ausländische Regierung in
diese Macht nutzen können um die Wahl zu
kippen wenn nicht sogar die Wahrnehmung
der Menschen der Wahl zu trüben denn der
Sinn einer Wahl besteht darin das
Ergebnis zu legitimieren während die
sozialen Medien die Wahl delegitimieren
wenn die Menschen sie für korrupt halten
wenn die Leute denken dass sie nicht
fair war während die Leute glauben ob zu
Recht oder zu Unrecht das Algorithmen
die Wahl übernommen haben dann werden
Sie die Ergebnisse nicht als legitim
ansehen sie werden die Regierung nicht
das legitim ansehen das wird es für die
Regierung schwieriger machen tatsächlich
regieren zu können
in vielerlei Hinsicht ist die Nutzung
von Daten um die Menschen zur Wahl zu
bewegen und sie zur Teilnahme an der
Politik zu bewegen recht vorteilhaft
wenn Sie mich fragen wofür Daten gut
sein könnten dann dafür dass ich mehr
Menschen mit der Politik befassen ich
glaube also nicht dass politische
Werbung per Definition um ein Problem
ist ich denke dass die Art und Weise wie
Online Werbung funktioniert und die
Tatsache dass sie so viel Überwachung
erfordert um Anzeigen Profile zu
entwickeln ein Problem darstellt und
dass die Art und Weise wie man die
Zielgruppen anspricht so viel Anzeigen
Betrug mit sich bringt das sind die
Probleme ich glaube die Kanadier haben
Angst vor der Art und Weise in der
Technologie und Überwachung eine immer
größere Rolle in ihrer Gesellschaft
spielen aber ich glaube sie fühlen sich
machtlos
wir hatten also diese Vorstellungen wenn
du deine Privatsphäre schützen willst
dann bleib zu Hause wenn du deine
Privatsphäre schützen willst dann erzähl
es nur aber wenn du dich entscheidest am
öffentlichen Leben teilzunehmen wenn du
Informationen veröffentlichst dann wird
dir unterstellt dass du gesagt hast es
ist okay mit diesen Informationen alles
anzustellen und das ist es was in der
modernen Welt einfach nicht funktioniert
ich denke es ist wirklich ziemlich
schädlich zu denken dass wir das Problem
damit lösen können die Zustimmung der
User abzufragen stimmen sie zu oder
nicht denn der Fehler dabei ist dass
immer noch der einzelne gegen diese
riesige Organisation steht und die große
Kluft darin besteht dass sie viel über
dich wissen du aber nicht viel über sie
haben all diese Strukturen erfunden und
wir können noch etwas anderes erzählen
paulis Wahlprognosen hängen von der
anhaltenden Popularität von Twitter und
dem einfachen Zugang zu seinen Daten ab
aber wenn neue Vorschriften zum Schutz
unserer Privatsphäre oder zur
Einschränkung des Geschäftsmodells der
sozialen Medien in Kraft treten könnten
sie die Art und Weise wie Menschen
soziale Medien nutzen grundlegend
verändern
ich glaube nicht dass die sozialen
Medien privater werden es wird ein
Bedarf an öffentlichen Netzwerken
bestehen in denen Menschen Inhalte
erstellen können die jeder sehen und mit
denen sich jeder auseinandersetzen kann
darauf gehe ich auch eine große Wette
ein
ich weiß nicht ich glaube die
traditionellen Meinungsforscher haben
Angst davor denn das ist die Zukunft
[Musik]
es gab mal einen berühmten Twitter
Chatbot den Microsoft herausgebracht hat
ich habe den Namen des Chatbots
vergessen aber es war eine Demonstration
von KI natürlicher Sprache und es war
eine wirklich ausgefeilte die einfach
wunderbar
viele Leute bekamen Wind von diesen
kleinen Chatbot Twitter-Account und
fragte sich was können wir tun um dieser
KI beizubringen der beleidigenste und
wiederliste Twitter-Account der Welt zu
werden und das ist ihnen gelungen diese
kleine KI entwickelte sich zu einem
furchtbar rassistischen
fremdenfeindlichen Wesen so dass
Microsoft sie abschalten musste
ist das die Schulter k.i warum haben wir
Menschen das Bedürfnis so miserabel zu
sein und so gemein und so böse
[Musik]
uns gegenüber und dieses Beispiel an die
Maschinen weiterzugeben
[Musik]
wenn man schlechte Kinder sieht stehen
dahinter meist schlechte Eltern wenn es
also um künstliche Intelligenz geht wenn
es um all das geht dann ist das für mich
mein Nordstern ich muss ein guter
Elternteil sein ich muss der beste
Elternteil für pauli sein
[Musik]